Let's see, why don't we go next to why
don't we go to a movie, go from Florida.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Oh, it was good talking to you again. I remember
we talked during the Georgia runoffs. Indeed.
Yeah. Oh, I guess my is a question slasher rant.
Like, I'm just listening to these Republicans and
how they're talking about, oh, we can impeach the
president, a former president now. We can
move on this unity thing to keep talking.
It's honestly driving me crazy because it's like
you just saw what the president did.
He incited insurrection.
Democrats are saying, hey, let's hold them
accountable and the Republicans are going,
well, we need unity, you know, we don't it's
already divided as it is, and it's like.
It just it's boiling, my mother drew
this man, even though he's not in office
and just yeah, it's a terrible argument.
I mean, I saw Rand Paul earlier this week
say on TV, you can't impeach a president who's
no longer in office. That's not only untrue,
but remember, Trump was impeached while he was
in office. The impeachment is what happens in
the House. What happens in the Senate is the
trial and either an acquittal or a conviction. So
these are a combination of opportunists and
propagandists and people who don't actually even
have any interest in sticking to the principles
they claim to hold very dear. And my approach is
increasingly the Berney approach, Bernie said over
the weekend. Listen, anything we can do via budget
reconciliation without a single Republican, if we
determine we should do it and it's good for the
country, we're going to do it. We're not going to
find 17 Republicans to convict Donald Trump. OK,
well, then then then they won't, but that'll be
them on record. And we're going to go through the
I just think they are so disingenuous
with when they want unity and when they
don't and when obstruction is acceptable,
just get around them any way that you can.
Yeah. Like.
But I feel like the left and the Democrats, I feel
like our issues are, you know, policy like we're
trying to say, hey, Democrats push for 15 dollar
minimum wage, push for universal health care, push
for efforts on climate change. I think the right
is doing, you know, who is more sycophantic
to Trump like right now, Kolinsky said this,
but I don't know if he reported it or something.
But he said that on the day Fox News called the
election for Joe Biden, like pretty much the
majority of the Fox News viewers fled Fox News
and went to Newsmax. One American news that space.
Yeah, it's not it's not the majority. It's not the
majority. Fox has seen a down tick, but the
majority means over 50 percent. But I think,
you know, the proof is in the following. Look
at the people that just got themselves elected,
most prominently riding on the Trump wave, Madison
Cawthorn, Marjorie Taylor Green, Lauren Bobert and
those types. What what is the big policy that they
care about? What are their big policy positions?
It's about owning the Libs and riding the Trump
wave and saying we're not going to be communist
and socialist. It's completely vapid.
And one more thing before I let you go,
I don't know who Brian is by any
chance, did you say Brian Tyler Cohen?
Yeah. Yes, I do. I do.
Yes. So him and Tommy Lane on the issue,
as they did a bit before, I think it was before
or after the thing was after the election.
And the the moderator asked, oh, if Democrats
control the Senate, what's going to happen is
Brian Tavakolian admires how Cohen said, oh, you
know, the minimum wage, access to health care,
climate change. Is that a bunch of things? I'm
like, oh, that sounds really good. And then he
goes, so Tamilian and goes, oh, if the Republicans
control the Senate, what's what's going to happen?
And she just said, stop socialism and stop social.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, there are other Republicans
who would have other answers, but that is that
is the epitome of what's going on right now.
Politically, it's just unreal.
Anyway, thank you, Richard. I can't
wait to get that off my chest. Appreciate it.
All right. Thanks so much. We'll from Florida.
Let's take a quick break. If you're holding to
talk to me, please don't hang up because we're
going to go right back to the phones momentarily.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.